I've seen the climate apocalypse use
fear to induce something approximating
the same kind of level of tyranny as far
as I'm concerned that characterize the
vaccine lockdown help me sort that out
and understand where you stand I see
these huge levels of depression and
despair loneliness in kids and I don't
think that there's a single cause to it
um and I think blaming it on you know
depression about climate is probably
over simplistic in fact I think a lot of
the problems we see in kids and
particularly boys it's probably
underappreciated on that uh how much of
that is coming from chemical exposures
including a lot of the sexual dysphoria
that we're seeing I mean they're
swimming through a soup of toxic
chemicals today and many of those are
endocrine disruptors